so Rishi cup another loyal viewer when I
think visionary I think innovator it's
easy to look at what everyone else is
doing and do that can you share a time
you found success innovating in
marketing thank you I seen ya is she I'd
say and one of the guys got here on a
dish to market I'll give an example a
really example when I was in a start-up
I had a really great rock star marketeer
near water and this is where that when
we're in the cellar back to California
in 1997 and my challenge it's pretty
crazy lowering no name company and I
think the problem we're trying to solve
is when consumers called into that bank
or telephone company verizon or AT&T you
know they got passed around customer
service was appalling I'm we created
this great technology that allowed you
to have a single view of the customer so
anyway schools in for all these crazy
1-800 numbers they can actually be kind
of consolidated and then the company
could deal with you as an individual as
a human being and understand the legal
product relationships with that
competition so literally look at the
market may not said to they all said you
know the challenge is how do we with
income six weeks get on front page of
things like Wall Street Journal or
financial times and this was kind of
free digital pre-internet what the
internet was just going embryo and how
did he do it he said right let's connect
ourselves back to what we talked about
what are the issues that consumers
really feel what is that frustration
when is their anger what is their only
when they're hanging on for hours on
these customer service calls and then
they get passed around or they get given
another one 800-number they've gotta
call you know the anxiety and aggregate
of customer service and then what we did
at she was a really intelligent survey
what we did you know it's very simple
low cost it costs we sort of ran the
company on fumes which is a great way to
kind of think mentally as an
entrepreneur it's not about spending big
dollars so we did a really small
customer survey got about a thousand
people and then it was like a shock
horror story
you know what and then on the Monday
after six weeks it was on the front page
of the Financial Times in London and we
got calls in brown course and you the
thought leaders on this issue you're
absolutely right here on the money we
want to talk to you so I think that was
an example that was the end of the
marketing area where is all about
promoting and selling push it and now
we're in a different world it's all
about pullet being part of the
conversation it would be so much easier
now I said this on the last question of
secrecy on when you are a master is what
took three years three months years ago
now happens in three days and through
the power well you know what happens
doing here with this around believe a
really cool focused around seven
entrepreneurs and inspiring them to
really fulfill their dreams and pursue
their passions it's a great clarity
great sense of purpose and I think that
is is a I gave an example from 18 years
ago but that's still serve as well so
the lessons learnt there is marketing
dollars doesn't solve any problems the
real issues are what Evan said is
marketing is not a kind of adjunct is
called the business a Martin really
should speak to all the entrepreneurs
kicking off their businesses about what
we need to do to meet customer needs can
we actually connect the emotion for them
to solve their problems and take the
frustration out of their lives and they
are having really simply and
articulately in a very focused way and
then relentlessly cheap to that focus
hit the button in terms of what their
issues are and how we solve their
problems and then marked it and I think
what we talk on this lab around how we
market through social media and digital
channels does that that is the way
because you could be part of the
conversation and throughout that
conversation you know they'll buy at a
point in time when they're ready to buy
Evan what do you think my thought on
this you know I think you can pull a lot
just like a little curveball yes I think
you should be an innovator and at the
same time I think you can also pull from
other industries I think to too many
times you're locked into here's how to
do things in
in youtube world are in dancing world or
in you know whatever business that
you're in where you can learn so much
from other businesses and other
industries and apply those lessons to
your company and and that's what makes
you you because because you like League
of Legends and because you like you know
dancing salsa because you like surfing
taking lessons from those industries
that I've worked and applying it to be
the first one in your industry to do it
I take insane amount of knowledge fund
league legends from baseball from music
from things that I just love and that
makes my business better where other
people are industry don't they're doing
the same thing to everybody else is
doing and in an example one thing that
helped lift my brand was the first big
video that I made on YouTube that that
blew up was around believed and I got a
God of collaborate with me who did a
bunch of motivational videos and nobody
in the entrepreneur space and have her
collaborate with him were done anything
similar and I work with him because I
liked his video and I was just watching
for my own interest put it up on YouTube
a bunch of people who I respected I
showed it to and they said that's too
long it's never going to work don't do
it that's where the little man idea came
from so that you've been trained to the
channel that maybe when I was over a
million views and that was my first big
reader that took off and that was from
taking an idea from a different industry
in applying it to mine and so you're of
their interests are fuel for you it's
money for you take what you love about
John Lennon who's your favorite singer
and apply it to your business because
he's already figured out a ton of stuff
even though it's in a different industry
there's lessons that can apply to your
software company everything's about this
the heart that companies with a heart
connecting with consumers with a heart
it's all about the emotion and being in
the conversation all the time and
creating the excitement and the blur
between kind of business and saturation
of life is is is gone forever so you've
got to be there right in the
conversation all the time and you've got
to be found first and exceptional over
the assailant it's gotta be you gotta
jump out a page and then from that point
onwards have everything authentically
consistent with what you're talking
about in terms of the message from a
marketing right
trot right through the service deputies
got to kind of match that up and you've
got to do with honesty and invariably
you know and I know every business has
things you gotta fix you got to be
honest with those you I think it's a
much more excited business world we live
in now than ever before I love that
extension that you just took us down
because a lot of people stop with the
marketing where it has to go on to your
product of your service right finishing
that you have because people buy
something based on the market and then
they get the product and it sucks where
that vision has to go through when I
load up your software or when I load up
your fashion magazine or when I come to
your dance class I want to feel the lies
that I got in the advertising and we
don't make that connection people are
gonna they're gonna drop and you're
gonna get negative word-of-mouth
spreading so thank you for taking us
deeper because I think a lot of people
just stopped at the marketing and don't
realize that the product is also
marketing the service is marketing how
you deal with your customers Marty
emotions much mr. company